stefan feucht bank ist brite fast sein
ganzes leben schon geboren aber wird er
1937 in berlin
mein vater war österreicher meine mutter
deutsche er war jude
sie war halb 1938 am abend bevor nazi
deutschland österreich annektiert flieht
feuchtwangers familie aus berlin
mein vater hat meine mutter in der stadt
getroffen und sagte geh nach hause
schnapp dir das kind nimm den koffer wir
treffen uns heute abend am bahnhof und
fahren zu meiner schwester nach
rotterdam am nächsten morgen so hat es
die schwester meiner mutter erzählt hat
die gestapo uns bereits gesucht weil
mein vater nicht mehr durch seinen
österreichischen pass geschützt war
die nationalsozialisten neben den juden
erst die bürgerrechte und später
millionen das leben
feucht bahn will zumindest den deutschen
pass zurück laut artikel 116 des
grundgesetzes können deutsche und ihre
nachfahren die von den nazis verfolgt
wurden ihre alte staatsbürgerschaft
zurück bekommen feucht bahn aber wurde
abgewiesen
zu meinem ärger wurde ich abgewiesen
weil mein vater österreicher war
wenn er geblieben wäre ich kann gar
nicht glauben dass ich das jetzt sage
aber das stand so im brief bis zu dem
zeitpunkt an dem den juden die deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft von den nazis
entzogen wurde
dann hätte ich mich qualifiziert aber
bis dahin wären wir doch bereits tot
gewesen
beide werden wegen vieler solcher
ablehnungen hat sich nun auch der
deutsche bundestag mit dem thema
auseinandergesetzt
der brite felix couchman und seine frau
isabell sind gründer einer weltweiten
gruppierung die für weniger
ausnahmeregelungen im gesetz kämpft sie
waren im januar in berlin um der debatte
im parlament zuzuhören
doch die deutschen abgeordneten sehen
aktuell keinen nachbesserungsbedarf in
zwei zusätzlichen erlassen hatte die
deutsche regierung im august erst einige
einschränkungen abgeschafft couchman
reicht das nicht
die erlasse sind ermessensentscheidungen
aber artikel 116 ist ein grundrecht
diese menschen können ihren brief nicht
mehr zurückholen die umgebracht wurden
sie können ihren besitz und ihre jobs
nicht zurückbekommen
aber sie können sich die deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft zurück wo er am als
german citizenship jüngere nachfahren
sind ebenfalls betroffen
marcel marx großvater georg floh aus dem
nationalsozialistischen deutschland 1937
nach brasilien
zwei jahre nach den nürnberger
rassegesetzen nun will auch sie die
deutsche staatsbürgerschaft
ich dachte das muss ich tun
für die ehre meiner familie sie waren
doch solange deutsche mein urgroßvater
kämpfte sogar für deutschland im ersten
weltkrieg
marcella bekam zunächst eine absage weil
ihr großvater deutschland angeblich
freiwillig verlassen hätte ihr zweiter
antrag liegt dem amt seit fast drei
jahren vor
auch stefan feucht waren wir nicht
aufgeben
mit der neuen regelung kann nun auch die
herkunft seiner deutschen mutter
berücksichtigt werden aber seine geduld
mit den behörden ist fast am ende
[Musik]
es ist ein kampf in dem ich gleichzeitig
sehr involviert bin aber auch jederzeit
bereit aufzugeben wenn die bürokratie
einem so den weg versperrt dann werde
ich nicht weiter kämpfen warum die
deutschen so viele nachfahren die
anerkennung verweigern versteht feucht
war nicht ihm bleibt nichts anderes
übrig als erneut auf die entscheidung zu
war